my name is chin in this really the
feather chin looks like a saggy nuts
much like the rest of the world the
Avengers cast is still mad at Thanos for
dusting our favorite characters infinity
war and they can't stop swearing
especially Don Cheadle yeah I feel like
we're all feeling like Don Cheadle yeah
you can't find something that rhymes to
turn into suit to turn I know it should
but his name isn't grit so I would say
do grit and sit Mark Ruffalo Scarlett
Johansson Chris Hemsworth and more
assembled on Jimmy Kimmel Live to read
off a kid-friendly infinity war
adaptation called this was the mad Titan
Thanos sort of kid-friendly
unfortunately Thor should have gone for
the head yeah he blew it
Thor was it's it's it's a no one sees
them their star star-lord
you know either one should have been
turned into Stardust he got all
emotional about his girlfriend to some
yeah we're still playing the Thor
star-lord blamed a man I gotta do my
shameless plug here okay I actually
asked the directors the Russo brothers
about this what do you guys think of
people being so ticked off at star-lord
yeah I mean I look he's a character
who's gone through a lot of pain and
he's lost a lot of people in his life
but you know there's lots of choices
their characters have made throughout
the movie that sort of led them to lose
it wasn't simply that moment you know
the if you get if you go back to the end
of Civil War the entire the entire rift
between cap and Tony is sort of a thesis
for why they lose misspelled Thor gets
the jump on panels at the end of the
film but instead of sort of killing him
quickly he sort of does it in a way
where he can draw out his revenge
and engage with with Thanos in a way
that God really gives them a window
lots of blame game here so whose fault
is it that Bannos took out nearly
everyone ask look I get the humanity
argument but star-lord man man we won't
find out the fate of the Avengers until
it hits theaters April 26 and luckily
Captain Marvel is joining them this time
around
yes he is because before you didn't have
me hey new girl everybody in this room
is about that superhero life and if you
don't mind my asking where the hell have
you been all this time there are a lot
of other planets in the universe and
unfortunately they didn't have you guys
earlier this month et sat down with the
Hulk in Captain America at the Avengers
end game press day where Chris Evans
revealed there's an OG six superheroes
at Xchange what is the og six Oh like
know what is the texture yeah it's fun
it's a bunch of me pose that together as
Carly makes me wonder what kind of gifts
they're sending through to make Scarlett
Johansson not want to be in this text
change I gotta be honest I mute every
group text yeah I love being a part of
them but it's like a party where I'm
like I just want to be invited yeah it
gets overwhelming of course guys be sure
to subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm corny teza no I'm Ashton